uh speaking of youtubers um we're gonna
get we're talking about another youtuber
right now he's basically the king of
youtube in the uk in the uk this guy's
name is ksi you know this man right here
so casey is a rapper he's a boxer he's a
video gamer and but he is not is a
crypto expert this was a really nice
accent thank you thank you
um so this guy ksi by the way he begot
famous for fighting
one of the the paul brothers logan paul
he like the whole fighting thing that it
started with youtubers fighting each
other this guy ksi
fought logan paul
that's how it literally started say okay
logan paul see there it is there was
their fight logan won i actually think
ksi want to be i think does it really
matter does it really matter they
equally made it right there's a couple
fights when you hear these numbers right
here you're gonna realize that the paul
brothers are winning and ksi not so much
so basically i said he's not a crypto
expert
um so he reveals he actually took a
screenshot
um
of how much money he lost
trading crypto in 2021 so this past year
take a guess by the way he's worth 15
million dollars 15 million ain't no
slouch 15 million dollars there he is
right there he did beat uh logan paul
uh take a guess
how much money he lost trading crypto in
the last 12 months you're saying 1
million that's a high number yeah one
million how much do you think he lost
i'm going through the theme flipped on
your head
10 million wow exactly what the number
you think no way could it be that how
about this he sent a screenshot of his
binance account uh he lost
5.1 million dollars trading crypto
12 months a third of his work there it
is right there scroll up david boom i
don't know if you can flip it he lost
5.1 million dollars and he did a
screenshot to prove it why did he do a
screenshot he's starting a me like
this is what feels bad for me it's all
about content content content now we're
talking about this guy creating content
about this guy he lost five minutes so
basically he lost it doing a uh what's
called a risky
trading tactic it's known as leverage
trading if you know anything about
um trading stocks i don't know if you
know about this but this is also called
um buying on margin basically it's when
you take on debt and you borrow money in
order to try to make money but basically
when you lose you lose very badly i.e
5.1 million debt you take on debt you
basically borrow money
um from a broker and then basically
if the account goes down and you're
double in that exactly exactly so that's
how so here here's uh i'm gonna butcher
his accent again he says note to self
mate and everyone watching never
leverage trade to all our friends out
there who probably do leverage trade you
don't win you never win in a year of me
doing crypto i've managed to lose about
5.1
million dollars thank you austin powers
yeah my crypto experience has just been
a lot of losing
a lot of losing a few wins but then
again a lot of losing okay so here's the
question ladies
what the hell do you make of this thing
i know you're not crypto experts you're
not you don't even know this guy but if
a dude a friend of yours a guy you're
dating loses 5.1 million dollars how
angry do you get what are your thoughts
on this situation it's gambling it's
another form of gambling yeah it's just
it's like legal and it's and it's
popular and it's not just popular it's
it's uh instagramable it's social it's
not like casinos used to be this kind of
like dirty little secret thing that you
did in the back corner of a you know
a secret poker things and you lost money
made money nobody knew yeah now it's
public so when you're in the win it's
exciting but even in the loss there's
profits to be made so
i don't know it's just another form of
gambling i don't i
i think guys get so crazy it's like
drugs too i wouldn't want to date
somebody who's going on high highs and
low lows like that day trading crypto
that's exactly what it is it's drugs
okay do you know anything about crypto
or if this guy's going where your
thoughts oh i don't but i would ask who
your financial advisor is he probably
does not have one exactly okay
have you ever
you know interacted with a crypto guy
you've been you know sliding in your dms
anything like that and you know you're
not in miami everybody's a crypto guy
exactly you both live in miami so yeah
what are your what's your experience
with this none i mean i don't really
know anything about crypto you know get
away from that lane okay well not a bad
move how about you
people keep convincing me about like
nfts and things like that they're like
you're gonna sell your art better like
this and i just don't believe it yet it
just feels like it's not a real thing
but i know people are making money
all that stuff is happening like it's
happening that's true it's just a matter
of like i'm one of those people that
when i do my research i go down a black
hole and like i submerge myself in that
and crypto's just something that
me traveling the world and being seeing
different
forms of money and seeing different
things i just i don't like 100 fully
believe it but that's the way that
everybody does and i could be wrong but
also people have been doing it for 10
years like you said you started youtube
with 100 people who bought the first
like bitcoin yeah and when i was in
college i had to write a paper on
bitcoins you know you did yeah i had to
write a paper on bitcoins if it was
something that um i thought was going to
be the new wave or not and here i am
post college and cryptocurrency is still
the thing oh yeah and this was five
years ago that you did this i graduated
2017. okay five years ago
wow anyway here's by the way just if
forget about crypto forget about
you know because we're talking money but
we also talk about relationships dating
if your boyfriend lost a large chunk of
change it could be 10 grand it could be
100 grand but like lost whether that's
gambling like amber brought up what
would you do in that instance what would
you say to your man first uh we got to
figure this out make sure nobody's
coming for us
at the door oh what's going on here are
we straight or no you know and then you
know figure it out if this is the person
i'm with i mean i'm going to stick by
your side i'm going to figure it out
even if he's losing that kind of money
you're going to sit by his side um i
mean if i love this guy it's not my
money
if it's part of my pot and you're losing
and you're being that like risky i'm
also like okay are you gonna put our
house up next you know it's like right
but it's about making better decisions
right you know what i mean you obviously
you could take a horse the water but you
can't make him drink it so like be by
his side so you know red flag is this a
red flag for if a guy loses this kind of
money did he also make five million that
year
no he lost five million what i'm saying
and like if somebody's making that kind
of change and losing it but still even
if you're making five million and losing
five million likes your net worth is
zero at that point right yeah so it's a
little risky let me tell you why i
respect this guy
let me tell you respect this guy
everybody wants to talk about how much
money they're making right in crypto
here's how much money i'm making in
crypto i did this with ethereum my
dogecoin did this i'm a bitcoin
billionaire i'm making all this money
this guy's like yeah
i lost a shitload of money nobody wants
to talk about their losses okay nobody's
talking about how much money they lost
and this is a learning lesson for people
not everybody's making money on crypto
no some people are losing an absurd
amount of money you know who made money
on crypto people who got in 10 years ago
right people who got in
early on some of these coins
a lot of people are hearing about crypto
and you know they're hearing seeing
what's going on all these people are
making so they try to get in boom this
is how you end up losing money and aside
from that i don't know how much you guys
about about stock trading they're term
and there's long term the whole premise
of investing
is long term
saving and just being financially
responsible that's short term six months
12 months 24 months that's savings
three years five years ten years
retirement that's investing lots of
people don't under freaking stand so day
trading like listen to what he's saying
here
okay yeah my crypto experience has been
a lot of losing a lot of losing some
wins and then even more losing that's
exactly what's happening here so as much
as people like exactly as much as i
think he's a [ __ ] from trading all this
kind of crypto and and making all these
high-risk investments i do respect the
fact that he's honest about it because
that's one thing that people
are watching the mr beast of the world
and the jake paul because they're
freaking real they're honest they're
real people that are doing their thing
and more than anything people want
authenticity right so homeboy right here
lost 5 million but he's you know he's
gaining a lot of i guess fanfare from
people saying
look
i feel for the guy thank you but this is
an example of basically
um
what's really happening behind the
scenes because everyone wants to talk
about their weddings what you just said
though i think there's a danger in
because people think that those
influencers that that this is just being
real authentic but they forget just like
a celebrity there's a team that's going
on like behind them and making that you
know what i mean it's not it looks like
it's just oh yeah i just live this life
and things are so easy and so kids are
aspiring to be like that but they don't
realize that these people are making
they're putting two million dollars into
an episode then that guy has you know
styling makeup everything you know what
i mean it's like that's the problem with
influencers they look like it's just
this is my life but it's not it's a
production just the same
and then i think that's dangerous but i
i i i respect him for like breaking the
rose-colored glasses for because i'm
sure if influencers is number one the
second for young boys in high school
they're gonna be like i wanna make money
on crypto that's what i want it's
already happening for sure thank you